[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con donde hoy
nos acompaña marilú martens ella es
directora de care perú organización sin
fines de lucro que trabaja por la
igualdad de oportunidades para niñas
adolescentes y mujeres además es ex
ministra de educación del perú señora
martins buen día y un gusto saludarla
hoy vamos a hablar sobre la educación en
medio de esta pandemia y en los países
que usan alternativas para no dejar de
educar a sus niños y jóvenes le quieren
pasar preguntando qué tan eficaz es la
educación virtual y además si no es un
poco un poco discriminatoria teniendo en
cuenta que en la región de américa
latina muchos de los escolarizados viven
en la precariedad sin acceso a muchas
veces a internet e incluso sin radio y
televisión como por ejemplo lo vemos en
méxico donde el gobierno está aplicando
esta técnica para no dejar de educar a
sus niños
buenos días raúl muchísimas gracias por
la invitación efectivamente han sido
meses de muchos aprendizajes aqui en el
peru y ya tenemos cinco meses en las que
hemos implementado esta educación remota
y hemos encontrado muchas fortalezas
pero también se evidencia mucha
fragilidad en nuestro sistema y el
acceso a tecnologías es una de ellas no
nosotros acá en el perú y en nuestra
región tenemos un porcentaje muy alto de
estudiantes en las zonas rurales de
nuestro país donde el acceso justamente
a estas plataformas digitales que han
implementado muchos gobiernos entre
ellas la del perú que que yo saludo no
saludo él la rapidez el reflejo del
ministerio educación en implementar todo
este sistema educativo a distancia sin
embargo como dices si no vemos el factor
de acceso a las tecnologías educativas a
la tecnología en general a las
tecnologías digitales no es un este una
propuesta como quiera que vaya con
equidad ahora qué efectos tiene la
virtualidad en el aprendizaje formal y
en las emociones de los estudiantes
mira yo creo que ese es uno de los retos
que tenemos porque estos cambios
definitivamente muchos han venido a
quedarse y muchos nos han demostrado
también como a través de herramientas
que teníamos siempre hemos tenido pero
también nos dábamos el valor podemos
llegar a todos los rincones de las zonas
rurales sobre todo y la parte emocional
es una parte muy importante sobre todo
en el tema de la incertidumbre que
estamos viviendo no sabemos si esto va a
ser un mes dos meses va a terminar el
año así el siguiente año va a ser igual
entonces ahí hay una incertidumbre que
yo creo que tenemos que manejar y que
tienen que manejar las autoridades no
decir en los escenarios que se pueden
presentar qué vamos a hacer
a nadie se nos enseñó a nadar tan rápido
en medio del océano y con tempestades
entonces si tiene que haber un soporte
un soporte a los padres de familia
quienes son hoy día los aliados más
importantes porque los estudiantes están
en las casas y están en las casas y
todos están con un montón de tareas de
cosas que no manejaban antes solo tienen
que marcar entonces si hay que dar un
soporte muy fuerte en la parte emocional
de padres estudiantes y también de
docentes si ahora ya brevemente porque
se nos acaba el tiempo le pregunto cuál
es la importancia de la presencialidad
en la educación y en el desarrollo de
los jóvenes por supuesto
si tenemos que apostar por este sistema
híbrido que se nos presenta con
tecnología tenemos que definir el modelo
pero también queda demostrado que la
presencialidad es importante es muy
importante sobre todo en los años
menores de nuestros estudiantes cuando
son más niños necesitan más el espacio
el contacto la relación con otros
estudiantes con los profesores con el
mismo espacio es importante pero ya
puede haber una fortalecimiento del
sistema y droid / de hacerlo a distancia
y hacerlo presencial y la importancia de
la democratización de todos los
estudiantes y todos los docentes al
acceso a internet es una cosa un factor
muy importante para implementar esta
nueva este nuevo sistema que ya se no se
nos impone y este yo creo que se queda
así de señora marilú martens gracias por
estar con nosotros gracias por su tiempo
era marilú martens directora de care
perú y también ex ministra de educación
del perú hasta aquí cinco minutos
por el día de hoy hacer una próxima
oportunidad
[Música]